[Music]
I'm Dana Jacobson from CBS Saturday
morning welcome to the dish today we are
exploring mouth-watering Mediterranean
Cuisine we'll be bouncing around the New
York City area quite a bit in this
episode but we begin at Meadow Suite
restaurant in Brooklyn where our Michael
George got a taste of the countryside in
the big city
Chef Polo Dobkin trained with some of
New York's top chefs but now at his
Brooklyn restaurant Meadow Suite he's
found his own voice
and he expresses that voice by letting
his ingredients do the talking
seasonality Simplicity and really
letting flavors kind of speak for
themselves try not to have anything be
overwrought or overworked sourcing some
of his best ingredients from his dad's
own garden in the Hudson Valley he has a
very Green Thumb when we first opened we
just started basically working together
planting and bringing down going up
every weekend and bringing down produce
and we basically create our menus on a
weekly basis
his Creations modern American Cuisine
with Mediterranean inspiration like
these crispy baby artichokes topped with
shaved lemon parmesan and a creamy
garlic dressing oh this is great it
tastes very fresh the born and raised
New Yorker was already helping in the
kitchen at the age of five who did the
cooking growing up uh my father did most
of the cooking and then when I got to a
certain age I just kind of started
helping out did you have the bug from
the beginning or did it take time to
grow well you know what looking back on
it I think I had the bug from the
beginning and that bug led him to
volunteer at a culinary school while
paying the bills as a bike messenger I
just started volunteering you know one
day a week and one day a week left to
two days a week and then two days a week
led to three days a week and when I got
to that point I told myself that I
should probably just
get a job in restaurant and see how it
goes he studied at the French Culinary
Institute and worked at New York's
Gramercy Tavern and Dressler dress was a
wonderful restaurant one of the first to
go to Michelin star in Brooklyn sort of
ahead of its time if you want to say
back then it was just us Peter lugers
and Diner in this neck of the woods
his wife Stephanie who now helps run
Meadow Suite came up with the idea of
starting their own place she pushed
really hard to go out on her own which
takes a lot of Courage took a while to
persuade me to do it why did it take
some arm twisting I it's just you know
leaving your comfort zone and doing
something as risky as opening a
restaurant can take a lot they chose to
set up in Williamsburg in the exact spot
where Dobkin earned his first Michelin
star at Dressler you could have picked
any location to start your own place
yeah you chose here the energy
both from the people who live here and
the people that decide to work here the
creative
energy is
is through the roof at Meadow Suite
customers get familiar dishes with some
surprises like this burrata with figs
pistachio basil pesto and pickled
kumquats and Tyrene pasta with
chanterelle mushrooms and shaved summer
truffle that is fantastic
it's so creamy it's Rich well this one's
all about we're going for decadence
by putting an emphasis on seasonality
Meadow Suite earned a Michelin star just
months after opening what did that mean
to you I was it was meant the world it
was hoping that inspectors would come
and was hoping to get a Michelin star
did not expect to get it that quickly
and we've been blessed to be able to
keep it for as long as we have his
dishes with their vibrant colors and
flavors evoke images of Summer like
Scottish salmon on a bed of black rice
with coconut curry oh this is different
this is not what I was expecting we make
a fresh green korean house and just
Infuse a little bit of coconut or
infused a little coconut milk with it
and that's the foundation for the dish
like the food the indoor herb garden
might make you forget for a moment
you're in the middle of New York City it
feels like a little taste of the country
here in the city well that was
definitely part of the plan of the
design using fresh simple dishes who's
not going to love that
that's amazing to take diners on an
escape to the countryside tell me about
the customers here what do you want them
to feel when they come into Meadow Suite
we want them to feel comfortable
relaxed happy and looking forward to a
wonderful meal
coming up we head to the windy city to
meet a renowned top
s the dish
[Music]
Chef Joe flam added a culinary Crown to
his resume when he won the cooking show
Top Chef in 2018. since then he opened
his restaurant Rosemary in Chicago's
West Loop where refuses the flavors of
Italian and Croatian Cuisine here's
Nancy Chen
in this former Meatpacking District just
off the Chicago River is a culinary
Voyage to the sundrin shores of the
dalmatian Coast
at Rosemary dishes exploring Italian
Croatian Cuisine bring With Faraway
flavors yet familiar experiences
helmed by Chef Joe flam so you say that
you serve Adriatic drinking food what is
that exactly it's either things that
make you you know kind of thirsty to
have a glass of wine or things you would
want to have with some wine or things
maybe you would have because you've had
a little bit too much wine it's a
distinct craving inspired by traveling
flam aims to satisfy One Plate at a time
that's what we wanted this to be that
place where you walked by you felt an
energy coming off and you're like we got
to go in yeah you stop in and you have
that moment in time right the ambitious
Target is rooted in flims love of both
his native Chicago and family Rosemary
is named after his grandmothers as well
as the frequent herb that grows along
the coast of Italy and Croatia where his
wife's family is from the connective
tissue between those two places is so
rich and thick you don't need to fuse
the two they've already been doing it
for hundreds of years that Journey
includes the Croatian staple of grilled
clamps but in true Windy City fashion
Flames are dressed in butter married
with smoke ramps a type of Wild Onion
said to have given Chicago its name
cheers do you do that with clams
that's very good Pham also prefers to
start a big Feast with a little gem
salad it's a sweet brightness of the
radishes that come through a little bit
of that kind of salty nuttiness from the
cheese and then that like creamy just
buttery kaimak underneath there's just
like that rich almost like you know
ranch dressing quality to it of you know
a proper Midwestern salad you're trying
to evoke ranch dressing in your own way
We Are Who We Are we we know who we are
here we're not afraid of it
then there are hearty favorites like the
pork ribs Papa Nella and scrardine
risotto known as 12-hour risotto for the
time it takes to perfect inspired by
flam's wife's family recipe we braise
veal brass we pick it we take that
liquid we cook the rice down with that
parmigiano grilled chicken thighs on top
of it that's a lot of flavor to pack
into one dish it is and not a single
drop of that flavor is to be wasted
which is why plant bakes bread with a
recipe native to Croatia fresh each
morning so this is our house made with
Gingerbread so this took us a really
long time to figure out there's not a
lot of places that make the spread it's
shaped like a pita
kind of cooked like a pita but it's also
the interior structure of it's
completely different it's got the
chewing crumb of a real like bread and
then we use this as just a mop for
pastas a bread mop is just my favorite
kind of mop
that bread and much of the ever-evolving
menu is prepared on a charcoal Hearth
custom designed and inspired by the
large grills flamwood spot at roadside
canobas cozy taverns dotting the
Croatian Coast their smoke would often
remind barbecue in Chicago summertime
you're talking about bringing in
midwestern Hospitality into a restaurant
that specializes in Italian Croatian
food yeah but I think those All Connect
I think that you know very Italian style
of hospitality is also that Midwest
style fatality it's welcoming it's warm
it's you know inviting people want you
to eat they want you to stay a sense of
being home even as flam introduces a new
Cuisine to diners Croatian Cuisine
really isn't known that much in in the
United States and I think that was part
of the thing that interested me about it
I was like
this food is familiar I was like I feel
like I could cook this it was like you
know not saying like oh I'm you know the
foremost expert on Balkan Cuisine now
but of like I know how to cook Italian
food and I want to use it to tell a
story that I'm also trying to find out I
think it's interesting that you call
these dishes stories I love cooking with
people and just listening to them like
oh why are you cooking this years of
cooking with my grandmother and spending
time in the kitchen with her flam calls
his Italian grandmother Mary his first
culinary influence before going on to
train in some of Chicago's top
restaurants including Michelin starts
biaja and Stephanie izzards grown the
goat he's also cooked in some of Italy's
top kitchens where finding his skills to
bring Classics back home we're making
Pepe today one of my favorites
it's so simple but sometimes really hard
to perfect well I think anything that's
simple there's nothing to hide behind
right so it's all technique flam's
technique also includes a sense of
hospitality hard to miss is there such
thing as too much cheese think of
Midwestern amount of juice oh well then
let's just cut that off yeah that's
perfect that generous Spirit how Vault
Rosemary instantly and to one of
Chicago's hottest reservations when it
opened its doors what has this journey
meant to you
I mean everything we're literally
sitting in my dream right now I get to
do something that I love that I'm super
passionate about it's a part you know
this little community in this industry
is so important I has the south side of
Chicago shaped you it's definitely very
much who I am it's in your blood you're
from there you live there you die there
it's it's who we are it's a tight-knit
community it's Community focused it's
family focused for Flynn that
determination has paid dividends one of
the grandmothers that your restaurant is
named after has been here yeah my
Grandma Mary she doesn't live far from
here she comes in quite a bit what does
it mean to her that you named this
restaurant after her well you know I'm
one of 24 grandchildren on that side so
but I think I'm just trying to submit my
position as number one grandchild do you
think you've done that oh yeah for sure
it's not even close
you might call the levanos Family
masters of Mediterranean Cuisine they've
opened multiple Greek restaurants over
the last 50 Years Michelle Miller took a
trip just north of New York City to grab
a bite
we all know how to cook we all have
culinary backgrounds all we do is eat
think drink food we're cooking away at
home altogether for the levanos clan
nothing means more than the Greek
Traditions brought to this country by
their patriarch John and Chrissa the
family matriarch you went from washing
dishes to your own restaurant in what
three years I opened 14 restaurants up
to now in my whole life it's a lot yes I
was putting 14 15 hours a day seven days
a week my verification was seven years
later he worked his vacation so he will
have that extra money it was very
passionate
and I think I did a good job I think you
did
their legacy started with a luncheonette
it since expanded to more elegant fare
focusing on Mediterranean Seafood what
is it about the food business you love I
enjoyed making new dishes I always talk
with myself I emphasize a lot on a
seafood Fresh Fish Fresh always speaking
of food here let's just kind of go
through the realm of what we have you
see what we would be eating day after
Christmas our spanakopita the most
classic of All Greek dishes is pasticcio
which is a baked macaroni ground meat
Bechamel dish my mom's famous peas and
artichokes with fresh dill and onions
always beets with partially a little
extra virgin olive oil a nice bitter
Radicchio salad and rack of lamb with a
Dijon mustard breadcrumb crust this
second generation put its own spin on
the New York dining scene with moly
votes in Oceana in Midtown so the kids
kicked it up a notch yes they did Nick
the eldest sibling graduated from The
Culinary Institute of America and soon
opened the levanos restaurant with his
brother Bill his younger sister Karina
wasn't far behind I just graduated and I
was fortunate I had a few months off and
I'll never forget in the fall of 1992.
Nick said I just need someone to help me
in front of the house just help me just
give me till the holidays and that's it
and I never left
very close all over so it's like My Big
Fat Greek Wedding
that's true almost yeah the only thing
we don't do we don't do the lamb in the
front we do it in the back cheers
[Music]
the Greek diners of the tri-state area
are legendary up next we check out a few
of the Epic eateries you're watching the
dish
is it the food the culture or the family
atmosphere of Greek diners that captures
our imagination and tantalizes our taste
buds back in 2016 famed chef Bobby Flay
visited a few to find out
[Music]
you know those times when you're hungry
but can't decide what to order hmm what
will it be pancakes or paella a burger
or brisket it's gonna be a corn beef
Reuben no problem whatever makes your
mouth water is almost certainly found at
a Greek diet all right so let me just
get this right so you're gonna have the
the crab meat stuffed filet the French
dip you're gonna have a cheeseburger two
cheeseburgers one LT the other one
Deluxe medium rare and then you said
chocolate chip pancakes I got it yes
that's gonna be my order today good
stuff all right I'll get back to you
enjoy it's always good here thank you
good food cheap prices and fast service
keep the Bel Air Diner in Astoria Queens
packed with customers choosing from 1500
different homemade items on the massive
get this 18 page menu
how do they do this how do they have
your French toast with your vanilla
apples and then have popcorn shrimp
seafood paella and then they have a
whole like Mexican Corner some Greek
Specialties there's a burger list of
like 30 different burgers
do you have any idea how they do this
what's the magic but it kind of Moves
Like a well-oiled machine it's just like
all the moving Parts just happen and
it's magic there's no explanation for it
that's just the way it is Greek diner
boom so what is the secret
it starts with this man Archie de la
Portis a quiet but demanding head of the
family whose restaurant has been named
best diner in New York City
he came from Greece when he was 16
hoping for a better life you have to
work you have to work you only Diner you
gotta work more you're a slave eight
hours he met his wife Patty while
working in her dad's Diner you think the
Greek work ethic is a big part of why
diners are successful yes he's here 20
years hasn't taken a day off really is
that right yeah yep 10 omelettes right
here their oldest son Cal says another
secret to success is experience short
order Cooks who use a few simple
ingredients chicken eggs beef and
potatoes to make most dishes fast so you
got the burger going somebody else has
set to set up the plate and you call
down there for the eggs yes and then it
all comes together on one plate exactly
see that's
that's what I'm talking about these are
the little things that that don't
necessarily get done in like a regular
restaurant
pick up Now cal along with his siblings
Peter and fioni are being groomed to
take over when Archie puts his feet up
if they can handle it do these guys have
the work ethic that you have when they
get here no way when they come here when
they hear when they're here when they're
here you're getting them here sometimes
is hard it's better you have to call
them up get up anyway of course are you
guys willing to put in the hours he
thinks it takes to be successful in this
business well there are two of us so
yeah we'll split his hours down the
middle then yeah sure that's perfect
still despite the grueling hours there's
a reason they keep coming back my father
worked so hard to get it where it is
it's part of our lives like we grew up
in the diner it's a part of my life and
I want to like thank it for the you know
for what it's given me
it's a sentiment found in many
family-run restaurants but why are so
many diners run by Greeks that initial
wave of immigrants they come over open
diners and then their brothers their
cousins their sisters come over where do
they get jobs in the diner creatures
sort of take over foreign food critic
Pete Genovese literally wrote the book
on the subject he says Greeks brought
ideas from the Homeland but they didn't
call it vagina they called it caffeine
it's a place where the local the locals
hung out so basically a glorified coffee
shop a lot of open air it's the place to
meet your buddies there and it most
importantly it's a place to find out
what was going on in the community
gossip exactly local news local gossip
what is it and what is the American
Diner today that's exactly the first
place you go if you want to find out
who's doing what to whom you know this
local Scandal who's about to get
indicted all right so we got this
message for tonight for Nick and Maria
Callas children of Greek immigrants a
community family place is all they've
ever known my parents own the diner
together in Edison
and we basically grew up together
my father was the front guy and her
father was the chef in the back
and we uh our families knew each other
the couple bought the nearly 100 year
old Broad Street Diner in Keyport New
Jersey I always loved these little
stainless steel diners always wanted one
I got a phone call and we came down we
had breakfast
and that was it we said yes definitely
you know I loved it I fell in love with
it the town everything Maria works the
till we seem like you know everybody we
do it's really family friendly Nick
works the grill this is a special for
today we'll do a great combo Chicken
Souvlaki Tzatziki spinach pie and a baby
Greek salad oh I want that to go 9.95 is
that it yeah it's 9.95 it sells out of
course it sells out you're giving it
away for free this is the best diner in
New Jersey no wonder Pete Genovese named
it the number one Diner in New Jersey
beating out nearly 600 others quite an
accomplishment considering the state is
the diner capital of the world what do
you contribute to your success
my wife
[Laughter]
and with three boys Nick and Maria
Callas already have the Next Generation
lined up if they love it like it or not
I don't know if I would push him to it
but given what I've seen just with
family with us once you get in the door
it's really hard to get out it's really
hard to get out it is so nice seeing you
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 stream us
right here on CBS News I'm Dana Jacobson
we'll see you next time for another
helping of the dish
[Music]